thanks for coming yeah I've had a weird
career I've done a lot of different
things but today we're gonna talk about
the Python data bike shed so hi I'm Rob
if you go to this link the slides are
there there's also a notebook that goes
into a lot more detail I had a bunch of
examples for all the libraries I'm gonna
talk about it's all there but it's sort
of like too much to get into the
presentation I am ocean kid Billy on
Twitter and I just tweeted about this so
that's also a link to do all the stuff I
work it's simple if you're not familiar
with simple simple calm we're a bank and
my my pitch is like we're a bank and we
try not to be a terrible bank like a lot
of people hate their bank we try to be a
bank that you don't hate it's actually
it's a wonderful company it's a
wonderful place to work I love the
people that I work with we have
interesting data because we work with
like sort of financial transaction whole
data and we're hiring caveat we do a
little bit of Python we're mostly a JVM
job so we write a lot of Scala write
some closure and that sort of thing but
we we use Python as like the glue layer
for a lot of a lot of the stuff that we
do I like to start all of my
presentations with with sort of a
question like a foundational question
for like why why we're talking about
anything is like I have data it's July
2015 so you're sitting down and you want
to answer some questions so you want to
group things or you want to count things
or you want to average things or we're
going to add things what library should
I use the answer is it depends it's like
it's cop-out right so it depends it
depends on the application it depends on
what domain you're in it really depends
on what you're trying to do and the size
of your data and and like in your domain
yep so so enter the bike shed right so
we're very lucky to have a PI data
ecosystem where we have like sort of
domain and application-specific tools
and when we have a very broad range of
these right so I'm gonna make this
analogy right so make the analogy that
Python data libraries or like bikes
right so we can think about these tools
in terms of like analysis velocity and
data locality so how fast is my tool of
doing a thing and where is the data that
it is operating on so is it in memory is
it on disk is it distributed somewhere
all these libraries sort of address that
in different ways so cool you decide
well maybe if you're here and you
haven't using python much say why should
I use
Python for data analytics anyway so
while Python might not be the fastest
language for things like web servers and
there's been a lot of benchmarks on that
it's extremely fast for high performance
computing and numerix mostly because see
and maybe because rust in the future or
C++ but because we have a very fast
layer that can do they can do numerix so
back to choosing our library and our
bike analogy first for some of these
examples we need a data set so I've
linked to this diamonds data set
this was actually aggregated by someone
in the art community that community is
excellent that data set aggregation
they're actually way better than us at
like building packages around data sets
which is really useful especially when
like you're looking to do examples the
art community's done a really nice job
with with this sort of thing so this is
actually really familiar dataset for a
lot of people because it's used for a
lot of examples so this is the Diamonds
dataset so this is like each of these
diamonds has a carat and the cut color
clarity depth right and it's nice
because you have sort of a mix of
categoricals and you have a mix of
integers and floats so it's sort of a
nice example data set to use for things
so let's start with like my needs are
simple
I don't like dependencies I'm running an
old version of Python seriously I don't
want any dependencies so standard
library sure why not like we can we
could use the standard library to do
things right it's actually pretty
batteries included the problem being
like you start doing things like all
right whilst in standard Lib has a CSV
importer but I'm probably gonna have to
roll my own type conversions right so
it's like alright well I can use the CSV
imported that it has but then I have to
sort of check types myself so you know
that that's like some cognitive load
there's like alright well now I have to
build a type checker you know it'd be
nice if someone else did that for me and
then you're like well I want to group
some stuff so all right well I guess I'm
gonna have to write my own grouping
algorithm and someone's probably written
a better version than this but it works
right you can you can group things and
just and just straight you know see
Python it's fine you can you know you
can do sequel like stuff that's just you
know pretty simple straightforward
Python logic you know you don't need a
giant to do cluster to you know to
select a thing from a thing where
another thing is greater than a number
right that's just that's just Python
logic and then all these examples are in
the notebook and work and these are all
things that you can do
and Python right and see Python so so
you posit pythons like your city bike
right it's like reliable it's familiar
maybe a little bit slow the velocity is
it's a little slower locality you like
you're working in memory right you're
just working in plain Python so the
standard library works right you can
actually do a lot of very useful things
in Python and people been doing it for
you know 30 years or whatever but what
if you have 10 million rows rather than
50 thousand rows like do you really want
to spend your time writing aggregation
code like Cheerilee someone else has
done this before right someone else has
written aggregation code and it's
probably very fast are my functions
composable pure lazily evaluated if I
write Python do I care about those
things if you're Joe Cruz you probably
care a lot about those things right what
happens when my analysis gets more
complicated or uses time or dates right
like none of those examples dealt with
time and dates which is one of the worst
things to deal with when you're doing
this type of analysis and then like is
you know when you import a CSV it's like
is a list of dictionaries the way that I
want to work with tabular data and a lot
of other languages like that is sort of
like if you get results from a database
that's how you're working with the rows
right you're working with like lists of
maps essentially and so the first
question will answer is like well what
if I like a functional approach to data
analysis right and I like my thing you
know I like my functions to be purity
and composable and all these functional
things that people like to talk about I
like to think of things in terms of map
producer and filtering I like composing
data pipelines and you know sort of
streaming data through and python has
all this nice yield and yield from and
generator stuff that is that is lazily
evaluated so let's talk about the pools
library so tools was originally written
by Matt Rocklin and basically it builds
a bunch of nice functional operators on
top of note C Python right so you can do
functional things like you know I can
map over a thing and then concatenate
them all together into a final thing it
is lazy so it tries to use like if you
can use it or tools it will use it or
tools to do things right so you know you
need take and then you need to like
evaluate it and you need to call list on
that so eventually to essentially
evaluate it
you can do like sequel like things right
with tools like alright I just I just
want counts so tools has like a
frequencies thing or it's like all right
I want counts of color that's pretty
straightforward to do you have a little
comprehension and then you say I want
frequencies even though more complex
right I'm gonna counts of things from
diamonds where price is greater than
1000 and I want to do some grouping the
cool thing about functional programming
is like there's a lot of ways to get at
something right so this is an example
we're sort of typing a filter and then
we're mapping across the thing and then
we're counting things and then we're
turning that into a dictionary at the
end so this is one way to look at that
this is another way to look at that
right so all right we can do a thread
last where everything that we pipe in is
going to be the argument for the next
thing and so we can do some filtering
and counting through thread last or we
can just look at this as a reduction
right so we can reduce across all the
rows of this thing and we can answer
this like this sequel query using a
pretty straightforward reduction so the
first person like of course tools like
functional programming should it be a
fixie well maybe but let's look at what
tools actually does so tools consumes
iterables dictionaries functions and it
produces intervals dictionaries and
functions right this is great because
we're building on data structures that
we already know we're already familiar
with so tools is more like your bike
tools right because it's a little bit
slower working in C Python it can be a
little bit faster because there's side
tools within which someone came in and
rewrote tools and scythe on and passed
the exact same test suite which is
actually a pretty cool thing to do and
it's pretty quick but you're still
working in local memory so you're still
sort of constrained by local memory
things caveat being we'll talk about
desk later which you can use with tools
but we'll get there so tools is great
but what if you don't like functional
programming like I don't understand any
of this I don't want to do mapping and
reducing all this stuff like I want to
work with tabular data please just give
me a tabular data interface also I have
to work with time and dates I'm
incredibly sad because of this give me
some way to work with these times and
dates so before we get into the rest of
the libraries a very very brief
interlude most of these libraries or at
least some of the libraries that we're
going to talk about use all these things
that I can only briefly touch on and I
like to think of these things as
accelerators right so scythe on is like
this superset of Python and you can call
in to see and make Python code very fast
no expert is like a very fast expression
evaluator for
for numpy number is JIT compilation to
LLVM all of those things are sort of
accelerating the code and a lot of
libraries we're gonna be talking about
so there's essentially the gears right
so they're the gears to our bike they're
what they're what let us change gears
and move faster within the libraries
that we're using and then I I don't
explicitly have an example for numpy but
like I can't not talk about it and talk
about Python data lives right because
it's sort of like the foundation on
which a lot of these things are built
everything that I'm going to talk about
from here on out is either influenced by
numpy is directly using numpy or has
like numpy helpers basically working
within the library numpy is still
critical PI data infrastructure
absolutely so we had to talk about it
it's gonna be used so end at the
interlude numpy is basically this right
so numpy is like one of the first bikes
in the Python ecosystem essentially all
right so I have tabular data
I want data frames I want like fast and
intuitive exploratory analytics I want
to really fast CSV importer I want to
interface with sequel I have time series
data help me please pandas all right so
a lot of you have seraphim Ilya with
pandas it gets talked about a lot I'm
not gonna get too deep into the example
it's got a very fast CSV reader you can
do summary statistics which is really
nice for data exploration going back to
sequel like queries you know select cut
in the mean of price from diamonds and
grouping by that's all just like a
one-liner and pandas right so going
through these examples you have to build
like with the pool stuff sort of like
convoluted examples with pandas most of
these are one-liners you can do things
very quickly write more complex query
same sort of thing you know you're doing
you know fancy slicing and then you're
doing some grouping and then you're
doing a count again you know another
another pandas example which is like we
can condense all of this logic down into
a single into it's nice single line of
code and then very quickly the one of
the things like I love pandas for is
dealing with dates right so you can
either pull in your own dates you can
generate your own date ranges you have
this concept of a date time index and
then you can do nice things right so
like alright well there you know I can I
can do some reasoning so let's say I
have you know data every minute I want
to resample to the day and I want to
mean all the points like I want to
average all the points and there
resampling so it has really nice
resampling let's say that I have missing
data so this is an example where like I
have
on the 25th the 30th and the fifth I'm
like alright well I need to fill in the
blanks essentially right so that's what
this is you can say I want to fill it
forward or I'm gonna fill it backwards
or I just want to fill it with with na
that is the thing you can do and then
you have a nice like continuous set of
dates so like I think of pandas is like
the gear commuter bike right daily use a
ton of features it's faster still
working in local memory but it's sort of
like in day to day work it's it's the
tool that I'm just gonna grab to do to
do a lot of my work so yeah it's like
the geared commuter of libraries so
panas rocks like I love I love pandas
and our analysts use pandas everyday but
there are some cases where you have to
think of data not just in a tabular way
right that you need to think about data
and n dimensions so you're thinking of
data in cubes or even like higher
dimension than cubes right so you're
dealing with like multiple cubes or
slices of data and you want to do fast
numerix and your arrays are homogeneous
but what you don't want to do is give up
on all pandas like nice labeling and
indexing features right and then
in-memory tables are bumming me out so
like this is one thing with pandas like
it's still working in memory and we'll
get to like some of the things that we
can use to help us there so we have n
dimensions we want to be able to
aggregate that data in multiple
dimensions maybe you're working with
netcdf maybe you have to deal with open
dot which you've ever done before is not
necessarily a pleasant thing to do so we
have this nice this nice library x-ray
so this was built by Stefan Hoyer and
and some folks at climate Corp and the
idea is we can have all the indexing and
labeling of pandas but we can do it in
multiple dimensions so what I have here
is like I have I have a two-dimensional
array I have some coordinates so I'm
essentially naming I'm essentially
labeling the arrays here I create the
x-ray data array and that's essentially
what this is right so I have x and y
coordinates and I basically have labeled
the Rays in two directions and so you
can aggregate right or you can do
selections based on like multiple
dimensions right so I say I want I want
the a and C labels I want just those I
just want just those arrays from a and C
so that's what this is it's got
broadcasting right so I'm like all right
I'm gonna I want to broadcast across the
whole thing it's just numpy behind the
scenes so this is a thing that it can do
right
but where it actually gets a lot more
interesting is when you start thinking
about not just like so that was a 2d
array sort of like a table but think
about a cube of data right we've got an
X and you've got a Y but you've also got
a Z Direction and you want to be able to
sort of aggregate in any one of those
directions right so this is essentially
a data set an x-ray data set that's like
a cube of data right so I have an X and
a Y and a Z so I've you know thinking
about is rows and columns and then I
have like x so the title tends to be you
know aggregated in time across the Z
direction so this is essentially a cube
of data so you can do things like
alright I'm going to group in the X
Direction and I'm gonna sum so if you go
back and look at this data and you can
you pick out like the the dimensions
that we're summing on you can sort of
see how x-ray is aggregating this data
across that dimension so you can group
in any dimension any of the n dimensions
you can group and then roll everything
up so I like to think of like x-ray is
like the BMX bike right it's a little
specialized but it's multi-dimensional
you can move in many different
directions it's faster you're sort of
still stuck in local memory kind of
again we have to get the desk which
solve some of these problems for us but
x-ray is awesome but so maybe we don't
have an N dimensional problem maybe you
want to work with like pandas like
expressions across many data sources
right so this actually common tastes
like I've got some data in CS fees I've
got some data in sequel I've got some
data in HTF I've got some data and some
other data source
I'm still running an in-memory problems
but I have big data maybe medium data
certainly maybe bigger than bigger than
I can Ram data and another thought is
like well do my expressions do do these
aggregations that I have need to be tied
to my data structures necessarily can I
build expressions that map across data
structures and storage and the answer
for that is yes that's why we have
blazed so think about blaze is just sort
of an expression engine that separates
expression from computation so this is
my basic Allah saying all right
blaze busy diamonds I'm saying you know
discover the schema of my data frame
with the Diamonds data and turn that
into a blaze data source and then I'm
like okay what type is this this is this
is a blaze expression this is the symbol
and I can and I can do things like
create these expressions so this is like
mean price so this is answering
of the sequel queries that we were
looking at before so these are just
blaze expressions you're not actually
calculating anything this is just pure
expression this is expressing how you
want to aggregate the data right and
then you tell blaze alright I'm going to
commute I want to compute this
expression on this data on this data
source so I have a data frame I have an
expression and I want to compute these
things so we actually did this earlier
if you look at the examples we already
did this in pandas now we're just using
blaze to do it but like the real secret
sauce is I can say okay blaze here's a
Postgres instance I can use the odo
piece of blaze to say take my data frame
dump that into Postgres and then I can
do the exact same computation against
Postgres without changing the expression
right and it's like a beautiful idea so
you're like alright I have this idea of
how data is going to be aggregated I
build these expressions and then I can
do that against multiple data sources
whether or not it's a it's a table
that's in memory or some giant Hadoop
cluster it's the same expression mapped
across different data sources and as you
can see like now instead of returning a
data frame it's returning a selectable
and then I can tell odo to say all right
compute this against Postgres put it
back into a data frame and I get the
same answer except as used Postgres as
the computation engine this is a really
powerful concept right because now you
can sort of work between in-memory
representations to like I kind of out of
core and distributed representations but
sort of like be able to work with the
same core expressions so blaze is like
your mountain bike right it's like multi
speed multi terrain because your
velocity is really varied based on what
you're using is your computation engine
and your locality is also varied based
on what your data source is and like the
idea of using expressions to do this
thing is sort of beautiful because like
you can map across these two things so
yeah plays great this is awesome but
what if you have lots of data and I'm
finding that databases aren't fast
enough like maybe we can do something
locally that's fast enough for me but
memory and disk space are sort of at a
premium is there some way that I can
compress my data and maybe kind of get
fast analytics out of like you know out
of compressed data is there more that I
can get out of my local machine so and
assuming my data is homogeneous can I
compress it and memory and on disk but
have that decompression be fast enough
that I can
actually perform useful analytics
against it and the answer for that is
yes that's why we have recalls
so because is essentially a compressed
data container so when you you can
create a sea table from a data frame and
this is what it looks like and it gives
you lots of scary looking data right on
like how much storage you're using and
like the compression ratios and that
sort of thing and then if you you know
you can actually take a look like
alright what are my compression ratios
like how good is be calls doing it
compressing my data in this case it
depends on your types right like some
data types are more compressible than
others but you can do data frame like
things against B calls either in memory
or on disk and it's even the on disk
representation is extremely fast right
so this is an example I'm like alright I
what I just did I'm gonna dump that
whole thing to disk and I'm gonna do the
same type of data frame operation except
I'm gonna pull it off of this to do it
and this is essentially what B calls is
doing so like B calls will create a
directory and there's like each one of
those be LP files is your compressed
data on disk and so this is this is sort
of the nice thing to write has been it's
fast and there's some real advantages
it's kind of a specific thing right
because B calls does not support the
full api of pandas it'll support some
subset of those things I think what
we're gonna end up seeing is people
building things on top of B calls rather
than seeing because it's like the
environment in which you use it but if
you find yourself like really getting
crunched and needing a compressed
container it is a nice thing to use and
it actually is very fast and it's like
an you're moving back and forth between
memory and disk and I actually think
because is a pretty big deal like I I
think we're gonna see some things built
on top of it being able to perform
aggregation uncompressed data sort of
huge for this like medium data analytic
space where we need to be able to we
want to do some stuff locally but but be
able to use data on disk so finally like
what if we really want like parallel out
of core computing right so let's talk
about desk we've you know you probably
or if you went to any of the sessions on
Friday Matt Rocklin gave a session on
desk this is like the the line enables
parallel computing through task
scheduling and blocked algorithms so so
here's the recipe for all of your cores
and or out of core computation so we're
gonna partition your array
it'll bowl iterables or your data frames
we're gonna perform blocked algorithms
on those and this is sort of it this is
a graspable idea right like we're gonna
take blocks of these things and that and
we can paralyze those like in in kind of
embarrassingly parallel operations so
we're gonna perform parallel slash
scheduled computations on there those
partitions and then we're gonna put the
pieces back together it sounds simple
kind of the secret sauce and what tasks
is doing is how it actually schedules
those things to make them efficient and
make them run like sort of like
vertically if you see a desk graph
essentially it's like this huge graph of
things and you want that graph to run
most efficiently and sort of the secret
and ask is like alright we're gonna
break up all these things and the
blocking is relatively straightforward
but the scheduling is sort of tricky and
that's where desk has some really really
nice nice stuff and how it works the
other secret of desk is that the API
looks like API is that we're familiar
with right so arrays are numpy like
right so this this looks like something
that you would do with numpy data frames
are data frame like I was sort of like
pleasantly surprised that I could drop
in some relatively complex data frame
expressions in here and just have at
work that being said there are some
things that are sort of tricky to do in
parallel things like sorts are hard
because your end up doing shuffles not
impossible but kind of hard and and I
think Matt rockland saying is like if
you need it come and talk to me if you
use desk and it breaks come and talk to
me and I'll try to get it to work
essentially and the same thing with
sequences right so so this is actually
pretty cool so I talked about pools
earlier and and I said well you know
Tools is based on like local memory and
see python sort of things but if you use
add ask sequence then you can really use
most you can use tools against your -
sequence except now it's fully parallel
it keeps fully out of core right and so
this is also a beautiful thing right
like all I did was copy and paste this
exact same thing from the tools demo
earlier except I dropped add ask you
know he calls it a bag I dropped add a
sequence in there and it totally worked
and it was fully parallel and and I
didn't really have to do anything
so desk is like our Panem right it's
fast and it's parallel velocity it's
quite quick locality it sort of depends
right it's in memory it's out of core
they're working on the distributed
features
but it's great it's it's like one of the
most promising interesting you know PI
data libraries that's out there so
what's left I just flew through a bunch
of things you know how can there be more
but we like we work in a very rich
ecosystem of tools so one thing that I
didn't talk about was spark you know
fast and general-purpose cluster
computing system we could do an entire
presentation on spark and PI spark the
original spark interface was sort of the
tool type things that we were saying
right some maps and reduces and flat
maps and filters and that sort of thing
fully distributed and you know you
distributed computations and if your
nodes go down spark can be smart about
how it rebuilds that pipeline of
computation to get to the you know to
the final answer spark also has
streaming and they have some machine
learning libraries built on that so
SPARC is like this fast multi-person sri
right or it's like fast and parallel and
distributed the the caveat there is like
this is where the analogy breaks down
because the story's not actually fast
but locality is like in memory on this
key distributed like spark is a spark is
a very good library when karma is were
standing here PI data talking about
people who have Python and production
and spark runs on the JVM right so spark
is all written in Scala PI spark uses PI
for J to compile Python code into into
Java classes and is a little messy and
the API always sort of lags behind the
mainland and and the JVM is not it's not
a zero cost abstraction right you can't
assume that for smaller jobs you can
just sort of use PI spark and call Java
and like spin up a job and it will work
like locally that'll work totally fine
but when you start to get like to bigger
data and actually running a spark
cluster like running the JVM takes some
work like you will have to have some
infrastructure engineers right on your
team spending at least a little bit of
time tuning JVM params and keeping
yourself from having like you know heat
bears and that sort of thing and like
tuning you know garbage collection all
that sort of thing so like it is a thing
that you have to think about so if you
put spark and you know in your stack you
know you suddenly have a JVM stack not
just Python so that is that is something
to keep in mind so if in that regard
right like spark is sort of like a bike
with square wheels and then like you can
use the spark from Python but
you also have to use it you also have to
like deal with the JPM so what about
there have been multiple distributed /
out of core and the array projects
disarray biggest Spartan I'm not sure if
any of those are actually like getting
maintained and continued bolt is
actually relatively new so bolt is an
NDA that's backed by spark and they're
talking about whether or not they can
back it by more more data stores and
this is X this was announced earlier
this week my slides keep changing cuz
things keep getting announced but but
bolt looks pretty interesting so if
you're interested in like a spark back
then the array they could take a look at
that it's a very crowded space right so
people have been working on
unlike distributed array type of things
for quite a while and there have been a
number of implementations this actually
wasn't a slide until this morning so I
went to two J's talk where the
cofounders of data is talk yesterday we
talked about s array and s frame which
is basically compressed on disk slash
and memory arrays and data frames and
it's very very impressive right what
they've built is incredibly fast and
scales - absolutely huge amounts of data
unless unless you have like truly
tremendous amounts of data we're sort of
getting to the point where you can do
everything on your local machine
assuming a local machine has a pretty
big hard disk we can do pretty fast like
compression and decompression of data
and and pretty smart algorithms looking
at pretty huge data sets right like oh
well I mean if you have you know
terabytes of data it like you know that
that might even be tenable based on you
know depending on the machine that you
have I didn't know what kind of bike
this should be but there their logo has
a dog so this is a dog on a bike so
quickly let's talk about Ibis just like
wes McKinney's the original author of
pandas this is his new project so we
talked about blaze and blaze is an
expression system that we can map to
different compute right so Ibis is the
same swift thing it's a pandas like
expression system that maps and pollen
had do the idea being that some things
are tedious and or difficult to do and
sequel much less Map Reduce right like
some some ideas are difficult to do in
sequel those ideas are really hard to do
in Map Reduce things like time series
queries and correlated subqueries and if
you look at the the Ibis api there's
like five different types of joins some
joins that aren't necessarily easy to
and sequel and the idea is that like
ibis will create expressions and you can
apply those expressions via Impala to do
but it'd be interesting if someone in
and like targeted Ibis at sequel right
that's a thing that could be done you
know they've sort of abstracted away the
expression engine and they can target
that at a different compute platform so
there's actually a bike brand called
Ibis so naturally Ibis we have an iPad
spike on here stats of machine learning
right so cyclic learn in my mind like
very clearly the benchmark for machine
learning libraries like both an API and
documentation if you've never read this
written read the scikit-learn Docs it's
probably the most amazing set of
documentation you'll ever read it is
really tremendous their API and they
have put so much careful thought and how
they build API is just a really
impressive effort in like how they build
consistent API is across their entire
library and then stats models the
statistical models and Python built on
our PI data toolbox so all of these are
sort of predictive analytics things
we're gonna look into the future so we
have a bike from the future right so
that that's essentially what these
things are and then finally at the end
of my abstract I said what should I tell
you that I tell you what you should
paint the bike shed with and the answer
right now like at this moment probably
is Seabourn which is a really nice
visualization library built on top of
matplotlib and bouquet which is like
just piling forward an amazing speed and
they have done they have built some
things in a bouquet they're actually
very hard to do right all the linked
brushing and linked plots and like
having servers that serve charts to
JavaScript front ends and like being
able to like map python things to
JavaScript things all those things are
very hard and like their team has done
an amazing job so if you're going to
visualize something in Python I would
recommend starting here because you can
probably you can probably answer your
question with one of those two libraries
at least in terms of like what chart let
you know can I make this chart so that's
it that was a whirlwind but thank you
all right
I think 31 minutes I think I have a
couple minutes for questions no no no
all right
oh yeah honestly honestly no I I mean so
a my familiarity with I have less
familiarity with our it seems like
they're sort of just like focused on on
the data frame and arrays and that sort
of thing but I I can't answer that
question as well in jvm world the answer
is no the reason that spark has gotten
so much uptake is because the JVM was
like not not good for numerix and doing
these type of analytical things right
numerix and JV and like in the java
ecosystem are not great certainly like
nowhere even close to where the Python
community has come in terms of like
doing numerical computation which are
why which is why I think like PI data
sort of like if you're doing like
scientific things why python is sort of
like you know the language that
everybody is moving to I'm plus it's
like a really pleasant language to work
in but in terms of like Java LAN no not
really we we are we do sort of have a
wealth of riches in terms of like all
the libraries and like really relatively
specific focus libraries and then what
we do so any other questions
so yes I would say that so there's no
like there's there's no reason that we
couldn't Park it blaze at Hadoop right
so we could you know we could we could
point blaze that Hadoop cluster and let
blaze do its thing against like either
Impala or directly against Hadoop itself
I think the desk project
I think it'll read from HDFS but not
Rocklin can answer that question I think
that's going to be another project we're
like yes eventually we can do
distributed computation with HDFS files
and like work with the doob directly
using tasks is like the computation
layer so yes III think like there are
some things that we can do with with to
dupe now um and python and like that's
only going to get better over the next
year I'm actually really like having
worked like purely in the JVM in the
past year and like looking at all that
like the Apache projects that are better
looking like working on top of Hadoop
I'm really positive unlike where PI data
is going for like actually solving sort
of big data problems in production like
at some scale things like traditionally
like Java has been used for like we'll
be able to answer some of these
questions with or we'll be able to build
some of these systems on Python and also
we'll be able to interrupt right so like
the parsley folks have built hooks and
like storm and Kafka that you can just
use Python for those two things to move
data and then like well I think we'll be
able to use the Python layer to actually
perform analysis on like like true Big
Data and we're sort of like in this
interesting place where we can also spin
up huge boxes and like you know kind of
used serialization formats non HDFS
formats to do like also truly big data
like s frame and SRA right like have
have their own civilization format
they're very fast for huge quantities of
data so so yes I think we will have
tools that work on top of HDFS and OOP
and I also think the way of tools that
have their own like secret sauce you
know and in terms of how they store data
that will also be just as fast and or
faster than that so
any other questions yep yeah I agree so
I certainly gave I gave a version of
this talk like a driver under this talk
a couple months ago locally in Portland
and someone at the at the end basically
said the same thing is like is any has
anybody written a blog post like
actually doing this I said well no
there's this right it's the presentation
like sitting on github yeah I totally
agree like someone should sit down and
be honest about like all right based on
your workload and your data size like
here's the library you should use and
and here's why essentially and if
they're really motivated they can even
put benchmarks right like because like
Matt I think you've done a really nice
job of saying here's desk here's what
it's good for here's what it's bad for
unlike their other libraries that will
do this better you know use my thing for
what it's best at essentially so any
other questions yep
whoo that's a good question so I'd say
one of my weak points is graph data I
mean I saw the the data folks demo their
graph stuff yesterday and it it like
based on like there's a little bit that
they talked about with how they're
implementing it algorithmically that
looks like the you know they've done
some brave smart things and made it very
fast I would probably start there but I
would say my graph knowledge is not as
not as keen as maybe there are these
other things so I would say start there
and just need to do some googling
because I'm not sure so all right I
think I think that's it I think it's all
the time we had so thanks everybody